this episode is brought to you by aura
o-u-r-a
it is the only wearable that i wear on a
daily basis aura is the company
behind the smart ring that delivers
personalized sleep and health insights
to help you optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device out there that you can
imagine
this one really makes the cut i've been
using it religiously for at least six
months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors aurapec's state-of-the-art heart
rate heart rate variability hrv
super important to me temperature
activity and sleep monitoring technology
into a convenient non-invasive ring it's
tiny
it weighs less than six grams and
focuses on three key insights
sleep readiness and activity so i can
use it to help
focus my attention on the type volume
intensity of
exercise that i should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol at different times of the day
affect
my sleep which they do and i can see all
of that in graph form trended over time
there are tons of actionable insights
that have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the
mega hit is ora's chief science advisor
as just one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables available because it
measures your vitals directly from your
finger
so it's not deducing that or
making a best guesstimate based on a
bunch of other things and trying to
triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the aura ring is 99.9
accurate for resting heart rate and 98.4
accurate for heart rate variability and
i work with hrv doctors and they
recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 dollars you can give or get the
gift of health
by visiting auraring.com that's
o-u-r-a-r-i-n-g
dot com again that's auraring.com
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free electrolyte drink
mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought when
i saw covid coming down the pike and i
usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto
low carb or paleo diet or if you drink a
ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking et cetera another
application if you've ever struggled to
feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because
even if you're consciously consuming
electrolytes you're just not getting
enough
and it relates to a bunch of stuff like
a hormone called aldosterone blah blah
when insulin is low but suffice to say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it rob
wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a former
research biochemist and two-time new
york times best-selling author of the
paleo solution and wired to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it
element will give you your money back no
questions asked they have extremely low
return rates element has come up with a
very special offer for you my dear
listeners they've created tim's club
simply go to drink element dot com
tim that's lmnt drink lmnt.com tim
and select subscribe and save on any 30
count box of element
for just 36 this will be valid for the
lifetime of the subscription and you can
pause it
any time again that's drink lmnt.com
tim for this exclusive offer and now
perfect for warm days they have a new
flavor
watermelon salt that i cannot recommend
highly enough
it is delicious
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
and i'm gonna keep the intro short my
guest today is hamilton
morris on twitter at hamilton morris
that's with
2r1s hamilton is a chemist filmmaker and
science
journalist a graduate of the new school
hamilton conducts chemistry research at
the university of the sciences in
philadelphia he is the writer and
director
of one of my favorite documentary series
that you can find anywhere
hamilton's pharmacopoeia pharmacopia
tomato tomato take your pick lots of
vowels at the end
in which he explores the chemistry and
traditions surrounding psychoactive
drugs his research has allowed him to
study psychoactive plants
fungi and chemicals as well as the
culture or cultures that surround them
in more than 30 countries
using an interdisciplinary approach that
combines anthropology and chemistry
his recent republishing of a book on
bufo alvarius hez
at the time of this writing raised more
than 150 thousand dollars
for parkinson's disease research you can
find him as i mentioned on twitter at
hamilton morris
instagram hamilton morris facebook
hamilton morris
and on patreon at patreon p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com
forward slash hamilton morris and the
reissued pamphlet
on what some of you may refer to as five
meow dmt at least derived from the
sonoran desert toad
can be found at www.psychedelic
toad of the sonoran desert dot com
hamilton welcome back to the show thank
you so much for having me
and i'm looking at a summary of our
first conversation
and we covered a lot we will have no
shortage of new material but for people
who didn't
listen to episode one i'll just provide
a few points that we explored quite
deeply
alexander aka sasha shulgin we spoke a
lot
about him news on him as well what is
the news can i tell you about his
his new book that's coming out no oh
yeah i don't even know if this has been
publicly announced but
sorry to cut you off right as you were
about to summarize this coming off
should i
allow you to finish what you were saying
no then no you shouldn't okay okay
i guess just very briefly for anyone
that doesn't know who alexander shulgin
is he was this brilliant
medicinal chemist who is responsible for
the discovery of
an estimated 200 novel psychedelic
compounds
and he wrote these two amazing books p
call and t call that came out in the 90s
and he died maybe five or six years ago
and they recently found some tape
recordings of a class that he gave in
1987
and they're publishing it as a three
volume set and i was
sent a review copy of the first volume
and it is so cool it is one of the most
amazing
because this man is no matter how you
define it
the greatest expert that has ever lived
on the gigantic subject of drugs
he understood the anthropology the
chemistry the botany the mycology
the law the history he understood every
dimension of it
and was truly a genius
and at this time in 1987
it was i think a very important moment
in
the history of drug policy and the
history of that sort of research
1987 being when this class was recorded
yes and it was i think a moment when he
was becoming
radicalized when he was realizing
that there could be no more playing nice
the way he had in the past because he
had this very close relationship with
law enforcement throughout his career
and then things were getting worse
in part not to go back to episode one
but in part because he'd done a lot of
work for established pharma companies
yes yeah he'd work for dow chemical he'd
done pharmaceutical research he'd
worked with law enforcement he'd had
deep ties to the counterculture he'd
done a little bit of everything
he was friends with everyone but during
the reagan administration
it was becoming increasingly clear that
things were getting worse and worse with
every passing year
there was an idea that okay psychedelics
have to be illegal because
they cause hallucinations and that's
unacceptable in our society
but mdma is different mdma doesn't cause
hallucinations and it can be used
therapeutically
and physicians were recognizing that in
the 1980s
and then it was placed in schedule one
so that was the first
moment i think where he started to think
this can't go on the way it's been going
on because they will
destroy every new medicine
that i create and then on top of that
they had just passed the federal analog
act as well
so this was a law that exists to this
day where they said
if you're making something that we will
arbitrarily define as an
analog of a schedule one controlled
substance we can
prosecute as if it is that controlled
substance
so if you are making dmt plus an
arbitrary number of carbon atoms we can
just say that that is dmt
and charge you accordingly so those two
things combined
the destruction of any potential use
of mdma and the passage of the
federal analog act had made him
enraged this was also the period that
led to his
writing and publication of peak hall so
this class that he's teaching
is razor sharp and extremely educational
and i think it's going to be wonderful
when these books are published this
summer
will the audio also be made available i
haven't asked them yet i certainly hope
so
please ask them if they would like a
cross-promotional opportunity to put
some of the audio on this podcast
i would be very interested uh to help
them
and so that shares a bit about
sasha sholgan who also i think it was
dave nichols
dave nichols or nickel nichols yeah dave
nichols
who is is featured prominently in one of
the episodes
of season three of your television show
who
had a lot of correspondence with sasha
and said that he was more he considered
him more of an alchemist than a
scientist
because he was almost like an
ethnobotanist not trying to preserve
a first person objectivity i mean he
consumed and tested many of the
if not all of the compounds that he
produced at least for tasting parties
and things like that
yes and was proud of it he made no
secret of the fact that he consumed the
compounds that he synthesized
and i think that there's an idea it's a
very
widespread idea that if you have
personal experience with a psychoactive
drug
this biases you in such a way that
the research that you do is not
trustworthy but this is
something that we don't evenly apply to
other disciplines
no one would ever say that an
ethnomusicologist is biased because
they've listened to music
or because they enjoy music themselves
or
that a sports commentator is biased if
they
have a past as an athlete instead we
would say that this
is something that makes him an expert
who is qualified to discuss the subject
so he was very open about the fact that
he'd tried an
enormous number of substances but was
not dependent on any of them
he did it in order to better
characterize them so that he could speak
authoritatively to his students
to law enforcement and to inform his own
research
really brilliant guy and this book is a
very exciting text it actually
gave me chills as i was reading it
because it's so good
can you tell people where they should
look for this yes i mean
i think you can pre-order it on amazon
alexander shulkin's family has a press
called transform press it's called
the nature of drugs that's a great title
it's a great title and
for people who don't know pete call
t call those are phenethylamines i have
known and loved and tryptamines i have
known and loved
respectively i mean these are
encyclopedic
compilations of
not just trip reports or descriptions of
experiences
but also details related to synthesis
yes and back to the experience i mean
that's been a big
part of this psychedelic renaissance is
talking about how the new wave of
researchers are these sort of
objective dispassionate people who have
never used them
themselves but not only is that not true
most of in fact all of them have used
psychedelics but they sometimes
publicly say that they haven't which i
think is not a good
way to go about this you know you know
there's a big difference i think between
long-term and short-term strategies when
it comes to
being part of a marginalized subculture
the short-term strategy is to be
dishonest
and to hide and to
lie about who you are and what you care
about because
if the dominant culture tells you that
it is wrong that it's immoral that it's
illegal
that's what you do you hide and that way
you can protect yourself
but that only protects you what if you
have children who feel the same way
they're not protected what about your
grandchildren if you want to actually
create a cultural change you have to be
open about who you are and what you care
about and
so one of the most disturbing things
that i get sometimes in response to my
show as a
is when people say oh you should never
talk about this chemistry don't you
realize if you talk about this chemistry
then they'll make it illegal you can't
talk about that synthetic root we've got
to keep it secret
you can't show yourself consuming a drug
then that acknowledges the fact that
people actually use these things and
we've got to keep it
a an objective clinical domain and
sure if the point is to distort reality
in order to sell something
fine but that's not what it really is
and that's not going to help people
long term yeah i
could not agree more this is also part
of the reason why
slightly different example but in the
process of fundraising
for say the psychedelic and
consciousness research center at johns
hopkins
or for phase three studies for mdma
assist psychotherapy when i was talking
to potential donors
it was a prerequisite in my mind that
they'd be willing to use their names
and not donate as anonymous
and thereby reinforcing
stigma that i think is largely unearned
so i wanted people to
not just take a public stance but to be
proud of their involvement
and to show there were some i know these
are slightly different examples but
reputational
upside potential not just reputational
downside potential
and also coming back to your
ethnomusicology example
we don't even apply the same standard to
researchers of
other drugs or compounds right so if
you're studying
opiates or you're studying morphine and
you happen to have been administered
morphine in the course of being a
patient in a hospital
right i don't think it is assumed that
that somehow
jeopardizes your scientific integrity
for studying those things later oh of
course not no there's a tremendous
amount of
inconsistency and hypocrisy in the way
these things are discussed and i think a
lot of it
boils down to puritanical objections to
euphoria
and joy you know i don't think anyone
would care about scientific
self-experimentation with topical
capsaicin
or something like that why because it's
not going to cause any sort of euphoria
and might even cause pain
and pain is dignified pain is good pain
shows that you're working hard
you're self-sacrificing that's all right
but if you're having a good time
that's a different story yeah i'm
contemplating where to go next
i still have three pages from our last
conversation
i don't think we'll make it through just
to give a quick
disjointed recap of the few things i
underlined
from our previous conversation bullet he
realized in high school
after taking salvia that psychedelics
were misunderstood and likely had more
potential than people realized
jump forward for those who would like to
learn more about psychedelics
neuropsychedelio uh by nicholas
langlets is that correct that's right
he's got a new book as well
wow so many updates is it out already
it's out yeah what's it called
it's um it's a meta primatology book
that's about
not about primatology but about
primatologists it's like the primatology
of primatologists
it's really good we will put a link in
the show notes to that new book as well
so team dot blog forward slash podcast
we will we will have that
we talked about your experience with
your cameraman in a hotel in china
with the synthetic cannabinoid you are
one 144 which led to a quote
fractal of uncertainty end quote that
was very unsettling
we have covered a number of stories of
the unsettling experiences one can have
or the
put a different way the dangers of
use of some psychedelics or more
accurately
use of psychedelics in uncontrolled or
improperly supervised settings
which includes documented
fatalities so i don't want to give
anyone the impression here
that these compounds are without risks
because there's so many other
factors that also come into play not
just the compound itself
and i have to give a disclaimer here so
excuse me hamilton while i do so but
nothing we're going to talk about in
this episode is intended to constitute
medical advice
we are not doctors neo-shamans
and this is all for informational
purposes only
so caveat emptor be safe out there don't
break any laws but
jumping to the next point real quick low
doses i want you to fact check me if i'm
getting any of these recaps
wrong but low doses of drugs
including say cocktails like ayahuasca
can be more beneficial
than the overwhelming what do i do with
this experience at high doses
that you have had low dose experiences
that helped you to see i think in this
case quote
the nicotine gum was inside of me end
quote
so there's there's a long story about
the nicotine in our
first conversation and we also talked a
bit about ibogaine
a bit about 2cd and then topics that we
might cover next time which is now this
time
including oliver sacks and claudio
naranjo so now
here we are in the present moment we
didn't discuss
we've already talked about sasha shulgin
a bit oliver sacks
or claudio how do those
figure into your life as influences or
how would you explain either of them
either of those figures
well those are just to go back to what
we were saying earlier
about people who are in the closet about
their drug use you know
of course when oliver sacks wrote the
man who missed
his wife for a hat and described the
medical student who's having the
olfactory hallucinations after using pcp
he's talking about himself but he didn't
want to acknowledge that he'd used pcp
because he didn't want to acknowledge
that he'd use drugs at all
you know he was addicted to amphetamine
for a period as well
possibly methamphetamine i don't know
there's a biography
written by lawrence wesler that came out
recently that i i know
lawrence wesler but i haven't had the
opportunity to read it it might go into
that
but yeah he didn't want people to know
as did you know many people
uh carl sagan would be another example
you know he wrote
a portion of lester grinspoon's
marijuana reconsidered
and talked about his revelatory
experiences with cannabis
but didn't want his name attached to it
right so you have all these
prominent brilliant minds that have
benefited from the use of these things
but they're afraid to publicly
acknowledge that fact
and that is i think damaging
but oliver sacks in general you know
he's he's
wonderful he's an amazing writer i think
he's one of the greatest science writers
that has ever lived
uncle tungsten the man who mistook his
wife for a hat these are really
beautifully written books his book on
hallucinations is also very good
so you can hear that airplane overhead
folks this is audio verite
if you hear palm fronds in the
background also
part of our experience in the world of
kovid i would imagine you have had to
pause
for audio a fair amount in your life so
much pausing the joke
that i remember someone told me one
point is they said
why does thunder come after lightning
because even god has to wait for sound
[Laughter]
alright so claudio yeah did you ever
interview him or talk to him
no yeah sadly yeah me neither
you know he wrote some enormous number
of books and i've only read the healing
journey
i really enjoyed that book me too yeah
me too
i mean i can't imagine being a
psychologist
and working with the patient for months
or
years and seeing such gradual change
maybe no change at all must be very
discouraging for
someone that really wants to affect some
kind of positive change in somebody that
they're working with
and then when you look at the sorts of
accounts that are described in the
healing journey
it's like a psychological fantasy
of having this you know these immediate
revelations that
affect profound and lasting change in
the people that use these substances
and of course there are similar you know
for people that are interested in
books that describe um
psychologists administering psychedelics
and
their patients having very positive
experiences there's another
book written by william richards
called sacred knowledge excellent book
it's a
really really good book it's kind of
half
clinical primer on best practices with
psychedelics
but then it also has a number of
biographical sections on
bill richards life which is just
fascinating
and i've been moved to tears by have you
seen the video of him
administering dpt to the dying cancer
patient
no i have not this was uh it was on 60
minutes in the 70s
and i mean it's one of the most moving
pieces of television i've ever seen
uh you say dpt yeah dpt although i don't
believe they specify it in the report
i uploaded it to my youtube channel
recently for anyone that's looking for
it
and watching people who are at the end
of their life
make peace with their own mortality in
the presence of their family
and the effect that that has on their
family
is it causes so many emotions one of
which is
it's almost infuriating to think that
this wouldn't be available to everyone
that might want it
when you see how beneficial it is and i
remember when i first heard about end of
life
psychedelic psychotherapy when i was in
my early 20s i kind of thought
what's the point of that if the people
are at the end of their life wouldn't
that be the lowest
priority psychologically wouldn't you
want to help people that have their
entire life ahead of them that way you
can
affect the greatest change but i had no
idea
that the way somebody ends their life
can have a tremendous impact on their
family
and if they are at peace with their own
mortality at the end of their life
that can relieve a lot of the trauma of
losing a loved one
i have not seen that video and i'll look
for it
on your youtube channel bill richards
for those who want a little bit more
context on him
is a beautiful human being i felt very
privileged to be able to spend time with
him
i don't know if he's still associated
with johns hopkins but he was for a very
long period of time
he along with mary kosamana who i want
to give a nod because she's
just an exceptional human and also very
experienced
supposed therapist therapist may not be
the right term facilitator
i don't know what term they actually use
within johns hopkins
but she and bill have they have one of
the
kind of larger sample sets
that is in the hundreds of sessions that
they have administered legally
uh mostly involving i would say
psilocybin at this point
probably in the kind of 30 milligram
range something like that but
bill is not just an excellent from my
perspective
clinician but he he also thinks very
deeply about
the philosophical theological
underpinnings and or
implications of administering these
compounds so for all those reasons and
more
i i definitely recommend that people
check out
his book have you met him before i've
spoken with him
i've never met him in person though and
he's so good it almost
worries me a little bit because when
people talk about the potential of
psychedelics i think one thing they
don't realize
is that the people that are working on
this right now
are the best people in the world bill
richards is one in a million
and by definition one in a million
people
are hard to come by you're not going to
have someone as compassionate
and skilled as bill richards working in
every
psychedelic psychotherapy startup and so
when we look at how promising the
results are
from some of this clinical research
that's coming out of johns hopkins
i think it's important to remember that
these are some of the most talented and
passionate people to ever enter the
field
and it might not be the case that all
these results generalize to a larger
population
though of course i hope they will it's a
really
important point i mean these are people
who have
been able to withstand in many cases
decades of not just resistance but
abuse by various establishments
so they're not fair weather entrance to
this space they've really
endured a lot and that includes many
people at hopkins including roland
griffiths
and many other research institutions
and i suppose this is as good a place as
any to say that
since you and i last spoke on the
podcast which is a few years ago a lot
has happened
i mean an extraordinary amount of
acceleration
has occurred in the research space as
well as in the for-profit
sector related to psychedelics is there
anything in particular that
worries you i mean we could talk about
the promise but then there are
maybe the concerns one of which i'm just
inferring from what you said would be
the assumption that we can scale results
and scale
in therapists based on say the
the results obtained through someone
like bill richards
although there has been a high level of
replicability within the
mdma phase 3 trials because they had
similar concerns
or similar questions at least related to
michael and annie mitthoeffer who are
very very skilled
therapists in the mdma assisted
psychotherapy space
and do any particular concerns come to
mind for you
well yeah i mean back to the shulgin
book there's a really funny moment where
he says that
every drug has no side effects for the
first five years
so if you're gonna use a drug you have
to use it in the first five years when
it comes out before people realize that
it has
any problems associated with it and
every new drug does have a hype phase
ketamine is in a type phase right now
then after the hype phase you enter a
more
sobering confrontation with its
limitations
right now you have a lot of people with
treatment-resistant depression taking
ketamine and they're experiencing
miraculous results five years from now
some of those people might start to
suffer urogenital
toxicity of one kind or another that
could make people less optimistic about
using this as a treatment casually
right it's known to cause damage to the
urinary bladder under some
circumstances and we're going to see
in a few years what happens with more
widespread use of it
so and cannabis is also somewhat in its
hype phase
where if we're talking about cannabis as
an intoxicant relative to alcohol which
sets the bar very low in my opinion
yeah it's great it's not going to cause
liver damage
it's not associated with overdose it
doesn't cause
the same sort of physical addiction in
the vast majority of instances though of
course
some people do develop problematic
relationships with it
but i predict in a few years we're
going to start to scrutinize a little
bit
whether or not it's a good idea to be as
stoned
as many people are all the time i mean
again i think it's almost certainly it
is certainly better than being drunk all
the time but
you know there's the cannabis
hyperemesis disorder which is something
that wasn't
discovered until relatively recently and
it seems that that's a product of
new patterns of cannabis consumption
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by dry
farm wines i'm a wine drinker i love it
love a few glasses over meals with
friends that said i hate
hangovers it kills me often for multiple
days right now
all of the wine in my house is from dry
farm wines also for my last two book
launch parties
all the wine has been from dry farm
wines why is that
because in my personal experience their
wine means more fun with fewer
headaches dry farm wines only ships wine
that meet very stringent criteria
close to sugar free so less than .15
grams per glass
lower alcohol less than 12.5 alcohol
additive free there are more than 70 fda
approved
wine making additives the fewer the
better in your wine
lower sulfites organic and produced by
small family farms
all dry farm wines are laboratory tested
for purity standards by certified
independent enologists
and all of their wines are backed by a
100 happiness promise they will either
replace or refund
any wine you don't love last but not
least i find delicious wines i never
would have found
otherwise so it's a lot of fun saves me
time and research
and i have fewer headaches other fans of
dry farm wines include the incredible dr
dom d'agostino who's been on this
podcast very popular guest
you remember the guy who did a 10-day
fast and then did
10 repetitions of deadlifts with 500
pounds that guy he drinks their wine
even when on a ketogenic
diet which can work dry farm wines is
offering you an extra bottle in your
first box for a penny because it's
alcohol it can't be free
find all the details and collect your
wine at dryfarmwines.com
tim check it out dry farmwines.com
tim and one more time i love this stuff
dryfarmwines.com
tim
are there any other compounds that you
think
are undervalued or over hyped
at the moment for therapeutic purposes
so let's just say
and this this could segue to your
experience actually which i'd love to
hear about
iboga or ibogaine for opiate use
disorder
or opiate addiction what is your
evaluation of that
i think there's a lot of promise there i
think there's a lot of promise for
pretty much all substance abuse
disorders and i
predict many sorts of
compulsions and addictions in general
which is something i didn't
fully come to appreciate until i went to
central west africa and participated in
these iboga rituals which gave me
a far greater appreciation of
both the ritual elements and kind of the
larger spirit of oboga
beyond its antagonism of the alpha three
beta form nicotinic acetylcholine
receptor
i think that's the first time i've
personally ever heard you use
spirit i know i i as i said it i said oh
did i go there and i just say the word
they say the s word
could you tell us more about your
experience i thought that episode of
season three
and do you say pharmacopoeia or
pharmacopia i ask this
every time pharmacopia is correct but i
say pharmacopoeia pharmacopoeia it's
always the battle of
do you say yeah there's endless ones of
these where you do you
look like an [ __ ] and say kratom
or do you say kratom like an american
and say it wrong both ways are
leaving aside psilocybin and our friends
across the pond what was your experience
like could you speak to some of the
experience
whether sort of phenomenologically
in the drug experience or plant
experience people prefer
or considering the ritual elements
what were some of the bits and pieces
that you felt were particularly
impactful because in that particular
episode
in contrast to some episodes like the
xenon gas episode
there's relatively little footage of you
yes
in the actual ceremony yes and that was
very important to me
i wanted to be entirely absent from it
and i have almost complete creative
control
of my show within the bounds of the law
but
one thing that was very problematic that
means
just within the bounds of the law just
refers to showcasing chemical synthesis
i mean even then i do pretty much
everything that i want to do but you
know i can't
i don't know depict myself committing a
crime i don't know that i would want to
either but the one thing that was real
there was a lot of pushback was showing
myself
and i didn't want to be a part of that
episode there have been a number of
boga documentaries made where a white
outsider goes to
central west africa and participate in
boiti rituals
and i felt that
this was one time i didn't want to do
that i wanted to show
the tradition and more importantly i
wanted to
show that the tradition is changing i
think a lot of people have this idea
of traditions as being the static
unchanging force
and in some cases actually there are
many aspects of the wiiti religion that
appear unchanged since anthropologists
documented them in the 60s
but one big cultural shift that has
occurred
is there are now opioids in cameroon and
gabon that were not there previously
there is no
tradition of using opioids in that
region
there is no heroin trade there
historically pharmaceutical opioids have
been far too expensive to be street
drugs
it just wasn't a market and the
naturally occurring opioids don't exist
there
so you have a new pharmacological class
of drugs
introduced to a new culture that didn't
grow up watching trainspotting and
requiem for a dream and christian f and
permanent midnight and
daytime television specials about
addiction we're inundated with this
stuff imagine if you'd never even heard
that an opioid is addictive before how
much more difficult it could be
to develop a responsible pattern of use
and so tramadol is being pressed in
ultra high potency tablets specifically
for the west african market and
they're extremely inexpensive and the
addiction has become pretty widespread
so what i found so interesting is that
what is the clinical application of
tramadol what's what's the indication
tramadol is sort of lycodeon
it is a low-potency opioid
analgesic that is unregulated in many
countries it is in
canada it's not a prescription drug in
canada until
a few years ago in the united states it
wasn't a prescription drug it wasn't
controlled
so because it's considered to have a low
abuse potential
it paradoxically ends up being one of
the more
used compounds because it's more
available this is like
what you know this is why it's really
hard to talk about abuse potential as
some sort of
intrinsic factor of a drugs chemistry or
pharmacology because it's so much
dependent on these social regulatory
factors as well
so tramadol is relatively unregulated
because it's considered
relatively non-abusable but ironically
gets used
all over the place for that reason and
it's a mild kind of codeine-like effect
but if you take a lot of it it becomes
less mild
and like all opioids if you use it
chronically it can induce dependence and
in some
instances problematic addiction so
the idea that ibogaine is an
anti-addictive drug is
not an african tradition that is
something that was discovered
in the united states by a new york
based heroin addict named howard lotzoff
do you know the story i don't
yeah he was a guy who in the 60s was
using heroin he was friends with a
chemist the chemist said there's a
psychedelic called ibogaine you might
think it's fun and that's all it was it
was just a psychedelic
and he tried it he tripped he had a fine
time with the ibogaine
and then when he came down he realized
that he hadn't used heroin and
he wasn't experiencing withdrawals and
his concept of heroin had changed
suddenly he didn't consider heroin
desirable he saw it as
symbolic of death and repulsive
and had no desire to ever use it again
and didn't and
dedicated the rest of his life to being
a sort of crusader for the
anti-addictive effects of ibogaine which
he had discovered
and they were later validated in
laboratory experiments with rodents
so it is pretty well confirmed at this
point in humans and rodents in a number
of different models that ibogaine is in
fact
an anti-addictive drug i don't know
the names of many researchers involved
with ibogaine
iboga or any similar compounds
was that in debra mash's laboratory that
those studies were done with rodents or
was that somewhere else
deborah mash may have been one of the
early researchers on it it's been
replicated in a number of different labs
this is one thing that's pretty well
characterized at this point and of
course they're also synthetic
derivatives of ibogaine like 18mc
that have slightly different
pharmacologies that also exert this same
anti-addictive effect that's
hypothesized to be derived from
antagonism of this one subtype of the
nicotinic acetylcholine receptor the
alpha 3 beta 4
nicotinic acetylcholine receptor so this
is not part of the tradition in gabon
because a there's no tradition of using
opioids
and because it's a religious sacrament
it's part of a religion called
buiti so
now that opioids are present in that
region
they are modifying their traditions to
accommodate
the treatment of local addicts and
that's what i wanted to document in my
piece
i thought the documenting of
a local being shepherded through the
process
by these boitie elders was really well
done i thought that was a very strong
episode
yeah and i think it is important that
they
understand that they have this amazing
medicine available to them because
it always also struck me as ironic that
everywhere else in the world
people are exclusively using and talking
about ibogaine as an anti-addictive drug
but the one place where there's actually
a tradition of using it where there's
now
a problem with tramadol they're just now
beginning to recognize that they can use
their own medicine
to treat people in their community and
it was really cool to see that happening
and to see how well it worked
providing that as sort of historical and
cultural backdrop
what elements of the experience stood
out for you personally since i can't ask
anyone else
about the experience that was depicted
in that episode
it is for those who may have some
experiences with psychedelics in the
let's just call it perhaps in the
western kind of psychotherapeutic or
pseudo
psychotherapeutic model where you you
lay down you listen to
spa music basically with eye shades on
this ritualized setting could not be
more different
it's the opposite of sensory deprivation
it's
the most stimulating thing i have ever
been a part of it's continuous dancing
continuous music continuous drumming
no sleep no food no water no break
maximum exertion and they divide
the ceremonial space into different
regions dedicated to different purposes
so
for people that are there for medicinal
purposes
they occupy a sort of recessed
zone where they lay side by side
and everyone dances around them and they
take such high doses of a boga that it
has an almost
anesthetic effect they'll even prick
people
to make sure that they're still
responsive to the sensation
and if they are unresponsive that's the
indication that they've had
enough eboga it's time to stop and
allow them to recover a little bit but
there's continuous
consumption and everyone must consume
babies children adults the elderly
everybody takes a voga but there is a
different dose for each person depending
on who they are
what they're doing in the ceremony and
what sort of treatment they're trying to
receive
and then it's really very amazing they
have
people that wear military outfits and
they are
an army a spiritual army who
guard the iboga ceremony from bad
spirits and they have
iboga guns and a bogan knives that they
use to
prevent anyone from entering that might
interfere with the healing of the
participants there's a lot of
incredibly beautiful symbolism in these
rituals including
burying people alive and i had read
about this and i
had always wondered if this is still
something that's practiced but they will
dig a grave and you will lay in the
grave on a boga
with your face up looking at the stars
and just your head protruding from the
ground and
you spend the night in the ground to
contemplate your own mortality
now i can't see that being integrated
into our
western medical practice but i can
imagine how profound that could be
even without a psychedelic do they
observe any cardiac
complications in their tradition i ask
because
my understanding is that there have been
documented
cardiac issues associated with
perhaps not iboga maybe it's ibogaine
administration in places like mexico
do they appear to run into any
health complications i asked about that
and they told me that they were aware of
people that had died
using it and so it seems that they are
aware there's no pretense that this is
a medicine that can't hurt anyone under
any circumstances they're aware
that it is very powerful and has to be
dosed very
carefully because ibogaine
binds to something called herg channels
and these are potassium ion channels
that regulate heart rhythms
a lot of topical anesthetics bind to her
channels and ibogaine actually has a
mild topical anesthetic effect
so if you take high doses of it
it can cause fatal arrhythmias
they didn't say that specifically they
didn't talk about you know observing
qt interval prolongation or something
like that but they knew that
it had to be used very cautiously and
you had to observe each person as they
used it
there's certainly a lot more to say
about how the builds
iboga there are many different
directions we could go this is as good a
place as any
to ask you to describe
or actually just answer the question is
iboga itself
this plant from which they derive this
sacrament
at risk or threatened in any way and and
this
is a question of sort of sustainability
as the global demand
for this continues to accelerate
yes yeah no i've been thinking about
this a lot recently and i
was thinking that it's funny that these
drug laws were ostensibly
drafted to protect us from drugs but may
have
actually had the only benefit of
protecting drugs from us
and now that more and more people are
recognizing the benefit of these
substances
there is going to be a tremendous burden
on the natural reserves of things like
iboga
ayahuasca buffalo various venom
not to mention the even more unusual
things that are out there
and for anyone that does recognize the
benefits of these things it's very
important
to take sustainability
seriously because medicinal plants
and especially medicinal animals are
widely documented to be destroyed when
they are integrated into a popular
medical practice
it doesn't even need to exert a
therapeutic effect rhinoceros horn
pangolin scale these are things that
have no pharmacological effect
whatsoever
although pangolin scales were reputed to
contain tramadol at one point
but they absolutely do not but that's
all it takes is someone to say something
like that and before you know it
pangolins are
severely threatened or even worse human
intervention with some of these
animals can cause the transmission of
viruses cause pandemics i mean there's a
lot of reasons
to be very careful about the way that
you interact
with animals in medical practices unless
it's absolutely
necessary to do so and i feel conflicted
about
iboga because on one hand i
want so much to sing its praises and
and talk about the tremendous benefit
that i think it had
for me even using it just this one time
but i know that when people hear that
and understand that the natural response
is going to be well i want to try that
myself
and in a boga tree has to be
about five years old before you can even
begin to harvest
the roots there's talk about sustainable
harvesting where you only cut off half
the roots and leave
the rest of the shrub alive i certainly
never observed that in gabon
every time i saw anyone harvesting roots
they would kill the entire tree there's
talk about
different types of sort of hydroponic
growth or
hairy root culture that can be done to
increase the yield
it could also be grown on a larger scale
i did see some people that had
small eboga farms in both cameroon and
gabon
it's possible but there has to be a
strong
incentive and the consumer has to be
willing to pay
the price to know that what they're
consuming has been responsibly sourced
so you know that i recently wrote and
published a blog post
on considering a more ethical menu
the piece was targeted at psychedelic
users or people who use
compounds that often overlap with
psychedelic use
or administration like combo yeah and
discussing some of the telescoping
potential ramifications of these things
becoming 10 times more popular 100 times
more popular a thousand times more
popular which is not
outside the realm of imagination or
possibilities at all
actually very easily could be the case
and
there are a lot of points that i tried
to describe
or make in this piece and people can
find it at tim dot blog forward slash
conservation
it's kicked up quite a lot of discussion
and also blowback because some of my
recommendations hit a lot of people
directly in the wallet
who are providers of various things if
we grab
one example let's just take buffalo
various
and 5mu dmt as an example
how contained is the ecological impact
of
synthesizing versus procuring it from
these
these toads i mean this is a fairly i
suppose easy example
and this is maybe a good example to
start with because others become
maybe a bit more complex to talk about
in the sense that if we're talking about
mdma
people can point to deforestation in
cambodia or they can look at the dumping
of various
chemicals used in producing mdma in
holland and so on and in other locations
but
how should people think of synthetics
and environmental impact is there a way
to
to minimize the impact in the case of
say 5 meo dmt
oh absolutely absolutely yeah a lot of
the examples that you just gave are
interesting because they're completely
true yes there's
deforestation in cambodia to
extract saffrol from these trees
but that doesn't need to be a source of
saffrol that's a product of the black
market
that's just because it can be done that
way you can make saffrol
any number of other ways you can make
mdma from black pepper you can make it
from catechol you can make it from
just endless different petroleum
products whatever there's
it's it's a relatively simple molecule
there's hundreds of ways that it
conceivably could be made
that don't involve the destruction of
old growth
trees in cambodia the only situation
where that is a necessity
is where mdma is a schedule one
controlled substance
and the manufacturing distribution of it
is controlled by the black market and
it's completely unregulated
it's sort of like when people say well
how could you possibly do cocaine
you're supporting the cartels and
i understand the point but the
issue isn't doing cocaine the issue is
the prohibition of cocaine
that makes it a black market commodity
that has to be sold by cartels
it could just as easily be a regulated
market like anything else like
aspirin so i think that there's
a lot of misplaced moralism in some of
these areas
um and synthesis does not have to
involve destruction of the environment
at all
five amio dmt especially because
you know you can make five amino dmt
from melatonin and melatonin i think is
produced microbially at least you know a
lot of amino acids are produced
microbially or
there's you know such an enormous
industry for the production of amino
acids
like tryptophan and that uh they've
figured out ways to produce those on an
enormous scale
with minimal ecological repercussions
so you can take 100 grams of melatonin
and convert that to about 100 grams of
five amio dmt
which is the equivalent of milking
thousands and thousands and thousands of
toads
and so the question is why not do that
well one reason
is that there's a sort of vitalist
animist interest in the fact that it
comes from a toad which i understand
i actually think that's really
interesting myself i don't want to
discount that entirely
and so then the issue is how can we make
synthetic materials have the same value
as something that is derived from nature
how could you feel that same connection
to a synthetic material because we think
of a synthetic material as something
that is soulless
something that is bad oh it comes from
some laboratory in china that means it's
bad it's dirty it doesn't have the
sacred goodness of something
that is derived from this toad that
lives in sonora
and estivates underground for nine
months just like the period of human
gestation and there's so much
beautiful symbolism there that of course
this is a transformative good experience
how could you find that same beautiful
symbolism in a synthetic compound
well what if you knew that the compound
was synthesized by someone who cared
who did it lovingly who is very
dedicated to purity i mean you hear
stories of nick sand
clutching the flask of lsd
as he synthesizes it and trying to
project love into the molecule itself
you know you can do this to a synthetic
compound if you want and you can
confer those same sorts of positive
associations
you know you can have animist
essentialist attachments to anything if
you want if you choose
and that's what i think is so funny when
people say how dare you say there's no
difference between
synthetic and natural that's actually
not what i'm saying i do believe that
there is a difference but i think we
have control over that difference
i think that difference is a product of
the value system that we have and we
could just as easily shift it if we
wanted to
furthermore i would say and this is also
what i wrote in that piece at one point
is even if we assume
that some of these animal or plant
derived
options are 20 superior in whatever
sense
to a synthetic i would find it
hypocritical
to inflict
ecological damage or encourage
increasing levels of ecological damage
in the name of pursuing one's own
healing
if other tools may be adequate
and for that reason also if we're just
looking at this
from a historical and cultural
perspective i think
lots of people and i'm not to malign
this but they want to kind of put a
stamp for every plant or animal
experience into their psychedelic
passport
and i understand the drive i'm a novelty
seeker i get it
but it's hard to find i don't think i
would say impossible to find any single
indigenous culture
that has used the entire pantheon of
psychedelics
it's just not something that we see
demonstrated by these
traditions that are venerated by the
very same people
who then reject a synthetic let me ask a
question before i lose the thread
for those people who might synthesize
because i watch footage
whether it's in your show or i do
reading and i hear about the dumping of
solvents and other things
after illicit manufacture of different
compounds what would your advice be to
someone who is synthesizing anything
in terms of minimizing how to dispose of
their waste or otherwise
to minimize damage there any
considerations and i'm asking this as a
non-chemist i've never synthesized
anything
right it completely depends on what
chemicals you're using
because there are many things that are
relatively innocuous you know you could
be using
alcohol as a solvent and then you could
just evaporate it into the air and it's
just alcohol it doesn't
matter or sodium borohydride might form
various borate salts that are innocuous
and then
you can do whatever you want with them
you can probably put them in your garden
if you want
and other times you might be working
with
mercury salts that are deadly poisons
and in that case it is your
responsibility
not to introduce them into the
environment where they could hurt
someone or enter the groundwater
and again this is why having a regulated
system is ideal because you don't have
to depend on
the good intentions of every single
person that's making these sort of
things you can leave it up to people
that are professionally invested
in doing the right thing that said
for every story that you hear about
clandestine chemists dumping
solvents and waste material into the
environment
there are actually a good number of
people who are aware of that stereotype
who go far out of their way not to be
like that
casey hardison is a sort of
controversial lsd
chemist who many people now have some
problems with but
one of the things that he was most proud
of was that in his entire lsd lab
all of the waste could be put in one
trash can that he he was
extremely aware of you know i'm doing
something that society says is wrong so
i'm gonna go above and beyond to do it
as
well as i possibly can so that no one
can accuse me
of having damaged the environment in the
process of creating this chemical
and i've known a number of other
chemists who have the same attitude who
actually
not only do they do the right thing they
almost take neurotic
pride in never doing any harm to the
environment with their synthesis and
there's a whole
subclass of chemistry called green
chemistry that is dedicated
to finding the most environmentally
friendly way
of producing a given chemical or a given
reaction
if someone let's just say ends up with
their garbage can of waste
i don't know if this is something we can
talk about but hypothetically how would
they dispose of that in a responsible
way and i know it depends on the
chemicals involved but let's just say
some of them are toxic
while minimally identifying themselves
as someone who is
engaged in illegal behavior does that
make sense i think of course of course
it's a really good question
and again i hate to keep saying this
again and again but it comes down to
one of the problems when something is
illegal is you could be somebody that
genuinely wants to do the right thing
i've got a little bit of mercury waste
i don't want to just pour this down the
drain i want to do the right
thing and give it to
a hazardous waste disposal company
but i'm afraid that in doing so i will
incriminate myself and end up in prison
and so
i don't want to risk it this is another
attitude that you
find and in those cases i don't know how
to advise people i would say that
before you get involved in anything like
that
make sure that you have a plan for
absolutely everything i'm not
suggesting that people indiscriminately
start
synthesizing these compounds that's not
what i'm saying i'm saying that
synthesis
is an alternative to harvesting them
from the natural world
for chemists that are trained and want
to do so
um i do have a sort of utopian vision
where more people are involved in
chemistry because
i actually think that one of the best
ways to reduce
problematic relationships with drugs is
to have people make their own
drugs and grow their own plants and i
think the same is also true of food by
the way
i think if more people grew their own
food and prepared their own food they'd
have
much much healthier diets no one would
be eating gummy worms
there would be a lot less obesity and
it's because
we are detached from
the process of manufacturing a lot of
the things that sustain our life
and if people grew their own mushrooms i
think
that they would have a much
better experience with those mushrooms
because they would know everything that
went into producing them i think the
same is true of cannabis i think the
same is true of mescaline containing
cacti
and i think although this is where it
enters a slightly idealistic and
unrealistic territory
i think that it's also true of synthetic
drugs as well
if you spent a year figuring out how to
make mdma
and how to dispose of the waste
effectively there's no way that you
would
abuse it by the time you were done you'd
have so much respect for what you had
created and the work that went into
creating it
you would have to take it seriously to
recap just for
the benefit of this podcast with the
assumption that most people are not
going to read the piece that i wrote
even though i'll plug it again it's
nothing for sale there
well actually that's not true there's
one link to your pamphlet on
uh related to five meo and synthesis but
all
proceeds from that go to supporting
research related to parkinson's disease
yes uh so people can read this at tim
dot blog forward slash
conservation but a few options in terms
of
lessening damage and i say this i should
say because we're talking a lot about
synthetics
as someone who's very fond extremely
fond
of whole plant-derived or fungi-derived
psychedelics whether they be philosophy
mushrooms or
ayahuasca which is a combination of the
benesteriopsis copy vine and most
commonly the chakruna or
psychodriveridis shrub leaves thereof
i've
derived incredible therapeutic value
from these things and i've
had to accept the uncomfortable truth
that a lot of the sourcing that is
currently going on
in the psychedelic world is just
unsustainable it is not scalable and
totally unsustainable
i'll offer a few alternatives for people
who may be interested in peyote
i would say please do not use peyote
reserve that for
indigenous use consider like you
mentioned
other mescaline containing cacti san
pedro regenerates much more quickly
combo i would say just don't do it
most civilizations have survived and
thrived and developed deep spiritual
practices without using toads
of any type psychological animals so i
would argue that you do not need to
either or you shouldn't
until you have exhausted all other
options the sonoran desert toad
buffalo various we talked about
synthesis options that have
i mean the yield is pretty incredible oh
yes i mean
this is the other thing is if you
believe in this medicine
and you want people to have access to it
this is the way to actually make it
available there's no comparison
to toads in terms of how much can be
produced this way this is how to
actually get it out there
and there hasn't been a lot of research
published on how
toad populations have been altered by
their
recent popularity but i think it's very
telling you know if somebody
is selling a product and they say it's
great you have to really scrutinize
the claim but if someone has
everything to gain and they're telling
you that they're doing something bad
not to do it you have to listen very
carefully so people that were
making their living harvesting toad
venom were telling me
this is not sustainable the populations
are dwindling
and they had every reason to lie about
that they could have just as easily said
don't worry about it
there's so many they're probably just
hibernating but they did not say that
they said that
there needs to be an alternative
available to people
and i actually see it as a
you know a source of inspiration if you
care about these things
then you can show your admiration
by studying them and trying to recreate
them synthetically to better understand
them
you know i think that there's a tribute
to nature in all natural product
chemistry
where you're recognizing this amazing
feat of enzymatic synthesis that was
conducted by a plant or an animal
and you're saying all right that's a
great challenge i'm going to see if i
can do it as well
i'm going to see if i can do it and if
there's more in the venom although i
don't actually think that there is all
that much that is
contributing why not try that out as
well you can synthesize bufoteen you can
synthesize serotonin o sulfate if you
want you can synthesize any of these
compounds and try them in different
combinations and
let that be a challenge and a way of
showing your admiration to the toad
let's stay on five meodmt for a little
bit longer
well specifically the toad derived
quote unquote toad as it's often
referred to
and i want to preface the question i'm
going to ask
that's going to upset people by saying i
am in love with many of the traditions
related to
sacred plants in central and south
america i've spent a lot of time in both
places i've
read libraries full of books
and have tremendous respect for these
indigenous cultures and traditions
that said let me ask the question
how much evidence is there to support
that there is
a long history of indigenous use of the
sonoran desert toad
as far as i can tell there's absolutely
no history whatsoever
yeah and it's a complicated point that i
tried to make in my piece and i think i
ended up confusing a lot of people
because
the history is that there was an
anthropologist named
jeanette runquist who had found
a cherokee midden pile that contained a
lot of toads
and had concluded i think maybe even
partially on the basis of some work
alexander shulgin had done
and her correspondence was shulgin that
it was maybe possible
that they were using it as a
psychoactive drug
which was a compelling hypothesis and
it's worthy of consideration
but subsequent investigations have shown
that those toads
could not have been boof befoel various
which is the only species that produces
five amino dmt
and that there's really almost no way
that it was any psychoactive toad and
that there's very strong evidence that
they were using the toads as food
so you have no evidence of a psychedelic
toad in that region and a history of
using
toads as food by those same people it
seems pretty clear
that you can't point to that and say
this is evidence of ancient
smoking of buffalo various venom it
simply isn't
but to make things more complicated this
misconception
served as the inspiration for an
independent researcher named
ken nelson in the 80s so he read this
article which got a little bit of
popular press in magazines like omni
which were very
very influential in the 1980s
and he decided to investigate it himself
thinking that he was
rediscovering an ancient practice but he
wasn't rediscovering it he was actually
discovering it for the first time
which is just a really actually very
confusing turn of events
but that is what happened he is
according to known history the first
human being
to smoke the venom of buffalo various
i mean just the trial and error and
balls
and also intelligence that are
encapsulated
by ken i mean it's it's really
mind-boggling
how much he was able to do and document
oh yeah i mean i think it's inspiring
because
it shows you know during the same period
in the 1980s
when things were looking really really
bad for psychedelic research
how one person could make such an
interesting and now
culturally very important discovery just
on the basis of their own
curiosity i'll also add one more thing
and please hamilton
call me out if i'm wandering astray
and getting things wrong but i think
another
element or aspect of this that might be
confusing to people
is i think what you're saying if i'm
hearing you correctly
is that there is no compelling evidence
to suggest
indigenous or historical use up until a
handful of decades ago
of the sonoran desert toad as a source
of five femo dmt
that is correct yes what you are not
saying is that there's
no historical evidence of
indigenous use of five meow dmt
containing plants that is correct yes
that's important
yeah that is the case but if if we're
looking at
toad specifically and and i'm i'm kind
of
beating this dead horse folks because
i've seen
how popular toad
has become in psychedelic circles and
it's
very very worrisome to me just in terms
of scalability so that's why we're
spending so much time on this
i should also say just as a caveat that
i have quite apart from the ecological
impact
seeing some very experienced psychonauts
get knocked sideways and untethered by
five emo dmt experiences
not to say that that is always going to
be the case
but at least anecdotally
among the circles that i know well it
has been alarming
how many examples there are of people
getting
destabilized by their experiences i
don't know if
if you have any thoughts on that oh yes
i mean i think one of the unfortunate
things about five meow dmt is its name
so people think five and meodmt that
must be
a version of dmt it must be similar to
dmt
but it's more distant from dmt than
silicon
and psilocybin you know it's a
pharmacologically and chemically and
experientially crucially
different compound it's so different
that
i don't even think the word psychedelic
really
fully captures what it is and what it
does it's
operating on a level that is different
from any
other psychedelic and i'm not just
talking about its potency there's
something else going on it's not
doesn't cause visual hallucinations for
most people it
dissociates you entirely from your
environment you become
largely unresponsive at high doses
almost as if you've taken an anesthetic
and it can produce very violent physical
reactions for people as well
it's really like a near-death experience
more than
what people think of when they think of
a psychedelic experience
for all of those reasons and more folks
please consider
other options or a synthetic route with
respect to
toad in the new season not to go from
like
horror to horror you explored xenon gas
yes uh so i think this is a a
useful place to talk about not
necessarily risks of
compounds but risks that can exist
external to the
compound or even the dose of a compound
itself
so we were texting about this a few days
ago but
can you provide a little bit of a
background on
why you have a gas in the most
recent season and what some of its
effects are and then
talk about what you observed in this
clinic that scared the living [ __ ] out
of me
yes yeah so for those that
aren't aware of xenon it is an element
it's on the periodic table of elements
in a column called the noble gases
it's on the rightmost side and at the
top you have helium which everyone is
familiar with then
neon which again everyone is familiar
with then argon which maybe a few less
people are familiar with
than krypton and then xenons you know
it's the heaviest noble gas that is not
radioactive then you have radon which is
unstable
and if you've heard of xenon you
probably only know about it
in the context of lighting it's used in
car
headlights and projector lights and
things like that
and it's very very rare in our
atmosphere it's point
zero zero zero zero zero eight seven
percent of earth's atmosphere
so there's a little tiny bit in every
breath that you take but
in order to concentrate enough of it to
fill a tank you need to
distill millions of liters of air you
have to
compress it and cool it down to a liquid
and then fractionally distill
off the nitrogen and the oxygen and
finally after you've removed all the
other gases you're left with a small
xenon fraction
which is why it's so expensive a single
breath
of xenon costs somewhere in the range of
sixty dollars and that's unfortunate
because
for anesthesiologists that have examined
xenon clinically
they've concluded that it has a number
of attributes that make it essentially
the perfect anesthetic
it is not metabolized in any way it can
be recycled
indefinitely it's extremely potent more
potent than nitrous oxide
when it's given to a patient they
recover very very rapidly
after the xenon gas is removed within
seconds and the anesthesia also begins
within seconds
and it has no known toxicity
so it is arguably the perfect anesthetic
and maybe even
the perfect drug it's incredibly
incredibly euphoric
but and this actually goes back to these
again i was saying earlier about how
there's so many different factors that
determine addiction when people were
talking about addiction potential
there could be the greatest drug in the
world but it doesn't matter if
a single dose of it costs thousands of
dollars or it's impossible to obtain and
i think xenon is an example of that it
is a drug
that is extremely enjoyable but
it's just something that nobody has
access to i never thought i would have
the opportunity to use it
and it wasn't until i was visiting a
chemist friend in new zealand i was um
in 2014 i was on my way back to the
united states i was about to get on the
plane
and he said before you go i need to show
you i have this tank of xenon
and i couldn't believe it that it seemed
so absurdly extravagant it seemed almost
on par with you know using gold or
diamonds as a psychoactive drug
and i had that opportunity to inhale one
balloon full of xenon and i
it was a cherished memory of this you
know one
absurd extravagant encounter with xenon
gas which is a source of fascination for
uh anyone that cares about the periodic
table
now when you say balloon
it was a balloon of sorts
may or may not have been a condom
so you talk about this perfect drug
i think you're talking about it as a
perfect drug from the standpoint of
euphoria i want you to correct me if i'm
wrong the first time that xeon ever came
on my radar
outside of hearing about it in passing
maybe in
high school on the periodic table was as
a
possible performance enhancing drug at
the sochi olympics
for endurance i think it was for
biathlon or
any number of other sports but that it
was being used
for endurance enhancing properties
as a performance enhancing drug i don't
know if there's any real
plausible mechanism to explain that but
what are the
medical uses
of xenon outside of inducing euphoria
first as an anesthetic but it's not used
for that in the united states at this
time it was used experimentally for a
brief period by
an anesthesiologist named mervin mays
and a few others have investigated it
but it has not been approved by the fda
for that purpose and all use is
experimental there is a pharmaceutical
company called
nobilis that's trying to develop and
release a xenon inhaler for ptsd they
actually sent me a prototype of it
which is the first time i've heard of a
psychoactive drug inhaler
for treatment of a psychological
disorder
very interesting idea i don't know if it
will ever come to market but it was
really cool to see somebody
looking into that in terms of
performance enhancing i think that it's
basically working as a sort of oxygen
deprivation type intervention
where in addition to the
anesthetic euphorian effects that
conceivably could allow an athlete to
get a little extra workout in
i mean this is i think among elite
olympic type athletes it would be far
too expensive to use
under any sort of normal training
and that was about it you know i had
this one experience i wrote it up as a
fun
novelty that i would never get to do
again
and then somebody wrote to me and they
said you know i was just in the sauna at
the gym and some guy said that he's
uh owns a xenon clinic what's the deal
with that
and i thought well i don't know what the
deal is with that i've never heard of a
xenon clinic
and i said you know could you get me
this guy's phone number and could i
talk to him and he said oh you know i'll
do what i can he sends me his phone
number we start talking
in the english language there's almost
nothing about this
this is all happening in russia czech
republic
india as well apparently but if you look
online at least
before i released my episode there was
almost nothing
about xenon is a psychoactive drug but
these clinics are opening up
where they give people xenon as a
therapy for a variety of different
ailments
and so i went and spent some time at one
of these clinics and it was a
fascinating and somewhat frightening
experience
it was one of the most surreal
i would say maybe that's the word
surreal
20 or 30 minutes of television i've ever
seen
i won't ruin the surprise but there's
xenon gas
there's operatic singing
[Laughter]
there are breatharians in other words
people who claim
to survive on prana alone without eating
food which ends up being particularly
relevant
when we get to the horror story that i
hope you'll
share it's uh
and also the bizarreness of hearing how
deep your voice becomes oh yes on xenon
yes yes it's it's really funny it's how
also funny i there's a number of videos
on youtube of people inhaling xenon
exclusively for the purpose of altering
the sound of their voice i think this is
another example of this sort of
puritanical
attitude that people have so all these
if you inhale xenon gas
to change the sound of your voice for a
youtube video that's totally fine
i upload a video of myself
inhaling xenon gas my voice has changed
but like everyone else i get high the
only difference is in the other videos
they want to change their voice the
highness is incidental in
my video i want to get high and the
voice change is incidental but in my
case the video is demonetized
[Laughter]
you back an alien hedonist i think that
it is sort of
emblematic of the way these things are
carried out in our culture
two people can inhale the exact same gas
but if you're doing it with the
intention of feeling euphoria
that's unacceptable but if you're doing
it to playfully alter the sound of your
voice then
sure that's fine you can advertise with
that since i've been dragging this out
with foreshadowing what was the horror
story okay okay the horror story yes so
in order to do the work that i do i've
had to cultivate a very
non-judgmental attitude and i often get
messages from people
saying you know how could you possibly
let this person say this or how could
you have talked to this or that sort of
person
but i think the best strategy if you're
trying to learn from someone else is
just to listen
and to not judge them and i've never
been the sort of
person that wants to catch people
looking their worst i always want
to give people the opportunity to be
shown the way they want to be seen
and i certainly did not go to this
clinic with the intention of making
anyone look bad the novelty of xenon
being used as a therapy was
more than enough for me and if people
had had a perfectly
good time and everyone had benefited
that would have been the episode
there was footage of people having
positive experiences yes
my experience was extremely positive but
over the time that i was there it became
clear
that there were some risks associated
with xenon therapy
they were giving it to children that i
don't think is inherently
bad but it does raise the bar in terms
of medical supervision
a lot of the research that has been done
in the use of xenon as an anesthetic has
actually been done on neonates so it's
not as if there's something inherently
bad about giving this to
children or in that case infants but
you want to make sure that there's
someone with training
at least as an anesthetist who is
available should anything go wrong
then there was the issue with people
potentially
developing a problematic relationship
some sort of dependence
and again you would never hear xenon
discussed
as an addictive drug because most people
don't have a tank of xenon they could
never hope to become addicted to xenon
but i think for some of these people who
are working with it continuously
they may have developed a slightly
problematic relationship with it
and i even heard a rumor that is
unconfirmed so maybe i shouldn't say it
but i heard a rumor that there was
another
xenon clinic operator in the czech
republic who
died as well so this is an occupational
hazard the same thing is true of nitrous
oxide it's a problem in dentistry that
dentists and dental hygienists
develop addiction to nitrous oxide
because they have tanks of it available
and it's very easy after a stressful day
to sit down in the dentist chair and
unwind for a few hours
i i spoke with one dentist who um
you know had pretty much
lost everything because he enjoyed
he told me that he wasn't addicted to
nitrous oxide
and he wasn't addicted to prince but he
was addicted to the combination of
listening to prince
on nitrous oxide
dangerous dangerous cocktail for your
professional future
yes so that's something to avoid so
the other thing of course is that when
you're administering an anesthetic
somebody is by definition unconscious
and if they vomit
while they are unconscious it can very
easily be
fatal if they inhale any of their vomit
so you have people laying on their backs
who haven't fasted which is
standard before in this clinic you mean
fasting was not it was not standard yes
but before the administration of a
general anesthetic someone should always
fast
because if you vomit while you're
unconscious it can be fatal so they were
not asking anybody to fast
this ironically breatharian someone who
claims to never consume food started to
vomit while they were unconscious while
wearing this mask which is
quadruple strapped to the face in order
to prevent any leakage of the precious
xenon gas
and it was absolutely terrifying
and that was a moment where i realized
you know i don't want to make anyone
look bad that's not what i
got into this to do but i also don't
want to hide
bad things that i observe because you
can very easily hurt people that way as
well
and it was a kind of difficult moment of
realizing that
there was something potentially
dangerous going on and i had to
acknowledge it the final thing that was
not captured on film it was not part of
the episode
because again xenon is so precious it
has to be recycled
when it's recycled it's passed through a
closed loop that contains calcium
hydroxide
which scrubs the co2 i wanted to film a
time lapse of this
color change indicator in these calcium
hydroxide
beads changing just to show the passage
of time so i asked a producer that i was
working with
to just inhale into the calcium
hydroxide repeatedly so i could
film this color change reaction and he's
doing that
i'm filming the time lapse i go into
another room to film something else
when i come back someone who's working
in the clinic said why don't we just
give him some xenon as well
you know he's here he's sitting and i
said you know it's very expensive you
don't have to do that
he said oh i insist i insist that we we
give him some xenon
and i said okay well it's very generous
of you and the producer wanted to try
the xenon
and so he hooked him up to the xenon and
i left again
and then when i came back 20 minutes
later not only was this producer
unconscious under the influence of xenon
the
proprietor of the clinic was using xenon
himself and was also unconscious
and wasn't watching him he couldn't wait
to use it himself
and that's when i thought okay there's
something that's terrifying there's
something terrifying going on here
and that same person tragically died
shortly after
we finished filming the episode so
you know i i don't want to
claim that xeon is dangerous i don't
even know that i think that those
clinics should be
shut down but i think that it's very
clear that
additional caution is required
you have a very interdisciplinary
bent and interdisciplinary approach
you have a journalistic eye you have
scientific training
you are a practicing chemist you are
doing research
and you have become this this figurehead
and magnet for all sorts of
correspondence so i think you have a
very good
30 000 foot view of a lot of
intersecting areas of interest and
activity within the
let's just call it the psychedelic realm
does anything come to mind
if i ask what would you like to see more
or less of
in the psychedelic space yes
one thing that comes to mind that i
don't have a good answer for but
something that i've come to appreciate
more and more as i've gotten older is
you know when i first started
researching the subject i was a pure
reductionist and
i had very little appreciation
for the ritual associated with a lot of
these things
and the more i experienced these rituals
the more i came to respect them
and the bogus ceremony was the moment
where i realized
that the ritual could be as powerful as
the substance itself and the integration
of that ritual
could dramatically magnify the
therapeutic properties of the drug
the reason that i felt that way is
because this is an endurance ritual it's
five days of fasting
five days of almost continuous dance and
drumming
and with the boga
you start to appreciate things that are
very
difficult to articulate i had a rattle
in my hand
and i was tired at times i
didn't want to rattle anymore and i
would think there's 20 people around me
that are rattling
do i really have to rattle
continuously all night long is haven't
we rattled enough
and then and then it hit me that yes
i did have to rattle because my rattle
motivated everyone else's rattle in the
same way that their rattle motivated my
rattle
and every single person's movement
played off of everyone else's movement
and it was my responsibility no matter
how tired i was to put
every ounce of energy that i had into
this ceremony
because i was a part of it and because
we were all connected
now that sounds like a pretty kind of
new age idea
but it felt entirely logical it felt
completely rationalist to me
i am a part of this everything that i do
influences everyone
else if i let my motivation slip for a
moment it could have an effect on
someone else
it could have a butterfly downstream
effect
that diminishes the entire ceremony and
i can't allow that to happen i have to
give this
every ounce of energy and enthusiasm
that i have
and that was part of it the other part
of it i would actually
liken bizarrely enough to breatharianism
which is
i've watched some documentaries on
breatharianism and i
you know after this experience i started
reading about it and learning about it
and it's
very very easy to make fun of
breatharians i of course would have made
fun of them because
of course you need food to survive of
course you need water to survive
obviously this is one of the most
obvious things in the world
but then i started thinking well wait a
second is it really fair
to just call these people idiots why
might somebody do this why might
somebody even
think about the idea of breatharianism
and what i
came to realize is that it's a
tremendously empowering idea
to think that there are reserves of
energy within you that you can tap
into and if you have enough will
enough power within you you can subsist
off your own life force indefinitely
and while there was no breatharianism in
the ebola ceremony i think that
spirit of reserves of energy within you
was a tremendous part there is
no need to get tired because there's
more inside you there's no need to eat
you can keep going there's no need to
drink water you're not going to die of
dehydration right there and then
you'll be okay you don't even need to
pee you don't you can just keep going
it's
all within you and that was a really
empowering idea
and it doesn't matter if you are
addicted to drugs or not it doesn't
matter if you're religious or not
the idea that there are tremendous
reserves of energy within you
is something that can benefit everyone
and i don't know how that could be
applied
in our current medical practice
um yeah the translation of ritual
although i suppose it's we already have
ritual
in our medical practices they are just
they just differ very widely from the
indigenous rituals right we've got
there's certain protocols and outfits
and hierarchies
i'm not saying they're unnecessary but
they form in some ways their own
codified set of of rituals and they've
started to introduce them you know
bill richards does talk about the things
that are done in johns hopkins
and you know they serve the psilocybin
capsule which of course is synthetic
psilocybin in a copal burner that's sort
of like a chalice
and they have a rose at the end of the
session that people examine
and which has become a sort of
psychedelic tradition
in 20th century psychotherapy in and of
itself
where people can see the rose at the end
and
in the petals they can recognize their
own mortality so
there are rituals that are being
integrated how widespread these will
become
is another question but i think that's
actually as big a question
as the chemistry and the pharmacology of
these substances is how
can we develop the best rituals to
ensure that people are getting the best
and the most out of them set and setting
right i mean
i want to pursue this same question a
little bit further but before i do
let me ask given the multiplication
of fly-by-night rent-a-shamans in south
america
and the fraud and disaster and sexual
abuse and other things that can befall
a tourist in south america are there
also fly-by-night operators
who are dealing in iboga oh i'm sure and
by the way
i am not saying this to
make any sort of claim like you have to
have a traditional boiti oboga ceremony
that's not what i'm saying at all i'm
really just trying to appreciate
the power of some of these traditions
and i actually think that they can
paradoxically be disempowering as well
if you think that you need someone else
to give you this experience
that you have no intuitive understanding
of your own psychology
that you need someone else to explain
life to you that's a problem as well
there's a balance and i actually think
that it probably helped me a little bit
that i don't speak french and so i was
able to absorb some of the symbolism i
was able to absorb some of the rituals
but i didn't fully understand any of it
and
i learned what i could i had a
translator i asked questions
but it would be a huge mistake to say
that i fully understood
their rituals i just think that
there's a lot to be done in the way that
we administer these substances
and the cultures that have spent a few
generations figuring it out
some of them seem to have done a really
remarkable job but that's not to say
that people should
invalidate their own intuition and they
should obviously be very very careful
there are some really
outstanding scientists who are not first
and foremost
psychedelic researchers who are going to
be coming into
this field who i think will do a really
nice job of
of looking at context and some of these
inputs although they might not
put transplanting of ritual
on their initial list they might be
looking at olfactory cues and things
like that but adam gazzali
at ucsf is going to be stepping into
this world i'm really excited
to see what he does i'm sure there are
others
let's talk about the ritual a little bit
further so i may get a little
far from sure with the initial question
which was what would you like to see
more or less of
we can just bookmark that i think it's
important to also note
which you already described in part with
this changing of
ceremony to address this
new problem of say tramadol addiction or
addiction
that they're experiencing in their
society or surrounding societies
that these traditions and rituals are
not
static in the sense that
one shouldn't feel that in order to have
the one and only authentic ayahuasca
ceremony they need to go find
a certain person from a certain tribe
because the real thing has been frozen
in the ember
remember amber has been frozen in the
amber
in a certain village in south america
that is to say that
people are have been mixing and matching
all along so if you look at the
traditional ayahuasca
and by traditional i mean pre-spanish
inquisition
kind of pre-mestizo tradition
ayahuasca ceremonies very often it was
only the ayahuasca only the
shaman all they wouldn't call themselves
that who would drink for purposes of
diagnosis or divination or
whatever the purpose might be prophecy
and
that if you look at even in the remotest
parts
of the upper amazon for instance some of
these ceremonies you're going to find
elements of other languages
say certain types of quechua that don't
occur
natively in those regions you're going
to find things like aguade florida
florida water which we both had
experiences with
which was originally manufactured in the
united states
and is a very strong cologne i don't
know how it's it
made its way into the remotest parts of
the amazon maybe you do i suspect
it might have something to do with the
rubber
industry that's a great question i'd
love to know the answer but you find it
all over the place
agua de cananga water also at least
one of the most common versions of it
initially manufactured in the united
states
and so these kind of synthetic hybrids
are found everywhere which is to say i
think we should give ourselves license
to continue
to experiment with these new
combinations oh
absolutely yes i mean christianity has
permeated
every great psychedelic tradition
internationally
it's part of the bui t tradition you bow
down to christ
it's part of mazatek salvia
and mushroom ceremonies it's part of the
native american church in the united
states
it's part of wechol traditions as well
it's certainly
present in a lot of south american
shamanism so i don't think i can think
of a single psychedelic tradition
that doesn't strongly include
christianity and christian symbolism so
that right there is evidence
that these traditions are evolving they
evolve to reflect the environment
to reflect the best
practices of the people who are engaging
with these plants
and i think that we have a lot of room
for growth and improvement
is there anything else that worries you
right now with respect to
the explosion of attention and
popularity
and capital the influx
of new participants in the psychedelic
space
like what are you most optimistic about
and what are you most concerned by
i'm very concerned by the hype phase
that we talked about
that there's a lot of people that are
interested in the money
and that's okay i don't think there's
anything wrong with money and i don't
think
there's anything wrong from wanting to
sell or profit from psychedelics
but it's definitely a problem if that
interferes
with people's appreciation of them if
they start
behaving in corrupt or unethical ways
and
journalists right now love to write
positive stories about psychedelics
because
the pendulum of novelty has swung in the
direction of describing psychedelics as
something new and good
and it's fashionable to talk about how
prohibition is a mistake and these
psychedelics are valuable medicines and
look at all these people at johns
hopkins university
they just did this or that so that's the
big new thing
well what happens when that gets a
little bit old and what happens when
i don't know someone has a bad
experience maybe a celebrity has a bad
experience and they decide that
mushrooms caused their psychosis
and then what and we start writing
stories about that maybe we went too far
maybe someone has some kind of problem i
mean historically that is the way
these things go they become very popular
then
art link letters daughter jumps out a
window or
someone decides that timothy leary is
crazy
and he's emblematic of the problems with
psychedelics and that becomes the story
so i just hope that everyone will be
responsible in their use and will
recognize that it is up to them
to ensure that the mistakes of the past
aren't repeated
what books there's a long list i've seen
your library
you have a lot of books related to
psychedelics
if you could assign
required reading for anyone involved
with psychedelics whether using
administering pursuing them
in the form of a business i know that's
very very broad but
are there any books that stand out
to you oh of well pee call and t
call are the two that i would say read
those first and
thankfully they're long enough that i
think if people actually took my advice
and
read them by the time they got to the
end they wouldn't need advice on
further book recommendations but
those are the the big ones you know with
iboga and buici religion
there's a very rare book that you can
find pdfs of online
by uchicago anthropologists whose last
name is fernandez i'm trying to remember
his first name
it's called uh bouiti that's the name of
the book published in the
60s or early 70s that's a great text
that's pretty much all that's out there
in english
most of the we t literature is in french
unfortunately
when it comes to silicon psilocybin
mushrooms
obviously there's terrence mckenna and
paul stamets that have
contributed really interesting books on
the subject depending on whether you're
interested in
cultivation or mushrooms in general
for mescaline containing cacti douglas
sharon wrote a beautiful book called the
wizard of the four
winds that goes into peruvian cactus
shamanism
that i recommend i could recommend a lot
of books they they might
be a little bit on the technical side
for the average reader
i mean there's there's a lot it really
depends on what you want to learn about
in some of these areas there's less
literature there aren't
many books that i would recommend on
five meow dmt and buffalo various with
in this very self-serving i'm aware with
the exception of this book that i am
republishing right now it's the original
book it's maybe 10 pages long something
like that 15 pages long
it's very short but i think that it
tells you
everything that you need to know about
buffalo various written by the man who
discovered that the venom could be
smoked ken nelson
and then i expanded it a little bit to
include some historical background the
whole thing is 30 pages long
it's a booklet very very short but i
think it it's good and i think that
the other books that are not scientific
texts like there's a
utexus monograph called evolution in the
genus bufo
but that's chemical analysis i mean it's
great if you're a scientist who's
interested in buffalo various
but in terms of a larger appreciation
of 5mu dmt i mean you have
other books but they tend to be a little
bit more in the new age vein
there's a lot of garbage out there yeah
on all of these things that we're
discussing
what is the url again for the pamphlet
yes that is
www dot psychedelic toad of the sonoran
desert dot
i wish i'd just gotten psychedelic toad
[Laughter]
well hamilton we've covered a lot of
ground and
we could go for another five hours but
maybe we'll save a little in reserve
for our next round i don't think there
will be
even if i exhausted myself i think we
would still have lots of material
it's about to get really interesting i
think there's going to be a lot to talk
about in the coming years
oh i think so too i think there's going
to be an
absolute cyclone
of activity and also
conflict uh intellectual property
being one of kind of the flagpoles that
i'm going to watch
very closely and innovation i mean a lot
of
novel psychedelics being pursued by many
for-profit companies
bigger and bigger players coming into
the space lots of research
centers being established at
various universities and i'm thrilled
that this
appears to be a field that is
more and more viable as a career path
for researchers and scientists
yes me too is there anything else that
you'd like to
say to my audience request of my
audience
a haiku that you'd like to read anything
at all
no it's just great talking to you yeah
you too man it's good to see you
and uh special thanks to the
red baron who did many flybys
in our audio verite conversation here in
downtown
austin and for everybody listening we
will put show notes
at team.log for podcast with links to
everything that we've discussed
and until next time be safe
be open-minded and try the hippocratic
oath when it comes to
psychedelics first do no harm or at the
very least
do as little harm as possible and thanks
for listening
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get
a short email from me would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the uh the world of the esoteric as i
do it could
include favorite articles that i've read
and that i've shared with my close
friends for instance
and it's very short it's just a little
tiny bite
of goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to
4hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by element
spelled lmnt what on earth is element
it is a delicious sugar-free electrolyte
drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw coppid coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus
salt which is a side note you can also
use to make
a kick ass no sugar margarita but for
special occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it rob
wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a former
research biochemist and two-time new
york times best-selling author of the
paleo solution and wired to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units
fbi sniper teams at least five nfl teams
who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely low
return rates elements has come up with a
very special offer for you my dear
listeners they've created
tim's club simply go to drink element
dot
com slash tim that's lmnt drinklmnt.com
tim and select subscribe and save on any
30 count box of element
for just 36 dollars this will be valid
for the lifetime of the subscription and
you can pause it any
time again that's drink lmnt.com tim
for this exclusive offer and now perfect
for warm days they have a new flavor
watermelon salt but i cannot recommend
highly enough
it is delicious this episode is brought
to you by
aura o-u-r-a it is the only wearable
that i wear
on a daily basis aura is the company
behind the smart ring
that delivers personalized sleep and
health insights to help you optimize
just about everything and i've tried
every device
out there that you can imagine this one
really
makes the cut i've been using it
religiously for at least six months now
and i was introduced to it by dr peter
etia who's also vetted
just about everything with advanced
sensors or packs state-of-the-art heart
rate heart rate variability
hrv super important to me temperature
activity and sleep
monitoring technology into a convenient
non-invasive
ring it's tiny it weighs less than six
grams and focuses on
three key insights sleep readiness and
activity so
i can use it to help focus my attention
on the type
volume intensity of exercise that i
should do in a given day
i use it to determine how certain types
of alcohol at different times of the day
affect
my sleep which they do and i can see all
of that in graph form trended over time
there are tons of actionable insights
that have come from using this ring
for me they have a number of incredible
people on
their team dr matthew walker a professor
of neuroscience and psychology at uc
berkeley
and also author of why we sleep the mega
hit
is auras chief science advisor as just
one example
the aura ring is one of the most
accurate wearables
available because it measures your
vitals directly from your finger
so it's not deducing that or
making a best guesstimate based on a
bunch of other things and trying to
triangulate
compared to a medical grade
electrocardiogram the orange is
99.9 accurate for resting heart rate
and 98.4 accurate for heart rate
variability and i work with hrv doctors
and they recommend
that i use the aura ring so try it
yourself it is
super cool and super practical very
actionable
the aura ring comes in two styles and
three colors
silver black and matte black i use matte
black
for 299 you can give or get
the gift of health by visiting
auraring.com
that's o-u-r-a
dot com again that's auraring.com
you